These female insects know the burden of carrying
a penis around all the time... because they've
GOT ONE.
Yes, FEMALES with PENISES.
WHAT?!
Hey everybody Trace here for DNews.
WHY are you a female or male?
WHAT MAKES YOU ONE OR THE OTHER.
It's not having a penis or vagina, that's
just a CHARACTERISTIC of the sex not the definition.
It's not even who carries the baby!
As you probably have heard, the male seahorse
carries the babies while the female buggers
off to...
I'm not sure where to, maybe that's another
DNews.
Anyway, there's no doubt in seahorses which
is the male and which is the female -- and
it has NOTHING to do with who carries the
babies.
Any ideas?!
Okay, I'll give this one to you, males make
sperm, females have eggs.
That's the difference.
That's all.
A new study in Current Biology released today
is challenging everything we know about vaginas
and penises -- because they're completely
swapped.
The female has a penis but still makes the
eggs, and the male has a vagina!
It's crazy!
The cave-dwelling Brazilian insect Neotrogla,
is the first organism ever found to COMPLETELY
flip-flip the organs, this female bug literally
has a big 'ol penis.
During intercourse, which lasts 40 to 70 hours....
amateurs.
Anyway, during that time, the female puts
its penis... thing called a gynosome into
the male's vagina.
Once inserted, it gets better ....... The
gynosome inflates and barbs on the exterior
lock the two nerotrogla together in what sounds
like 40-70 hours of horribleness while the
female of the species absorbs the sperm along
with a nutrient rich fluid the sperm live
in.
Then the sperm fertilizes the egg, and that's
where neotrogla babies come from!
[[STARE]] The scientists believe their low-nutrient
environment led to this unique sexual adaptation.
The female gains nourishment by consuming
the sperm and fluid during copulation, and
the male gets... well... gets to copulate
for a few days in a row?
I guess?
What's the point though, why do we even HAVE
these sex organs.
It's not like the penis or vagina help us
be better hunters or farmers.
Why did they evolve?
Darwin wrote in 1871 that he believed the
differentiation arose from sexual competition
... basically we evolved larger members or
brighter feathers because we wanted to attract
a mate.
In most of the natural world, the males have
the penises, because the eggs live inside
the females.
Penises have evolved to reach into the other
sex's body to deposit that sperm.
But seriously, giant bug dicks?
What the crap nature?!
The scientists believe this discovery will
allow us to study sexual selection, conflict
between the sexes, and the evolution of novel
sexual differentiation!
Of the 8.7 million species on the planet,
this is the ONLY ONE with complete opposite
evolutionary structures.
How do you feel about it?
Feeling envious?
Tell us your thoughts down below, and subscribe
here for more weird-ass science stories just
like this one.